what three things does a producer want
in a screenplay
I would say for for me personally I'm a
genre producer
I want originality
uh if it's not original I don't want to
have seen it for a long time
uh and I want it to be
90 pages
I I really do feel there are very few
movies that are horror movies that need
to be longer than 90 minutes typically I
mean you'll get to shining in different
things like that but but typically I
think that horror movies and comedies
should be 90 minutes get in get out see
the funny see the scary that's it
that's what I think
what are the top reasons you would
reject a screenplay
um it's not original or I've seen it
very recently
um you know is it an idea most of all
is it an idea I think people will want
to see
again coming back to it who wants to see
this movie right is there an audience
for this movie
if I don't think there's an audience
familiar I think it's a very small
audience then it's more likely a pass
from me
but have you watched a film or read a
script where
you can tell this wouldn't test well
going back to your marketing brain but
you personally liked it
I mean there are some scripts that are
in fact I read one it was just it's an
incredible script it's batshit crazy
it's not a horror movie but it's just
you know it's
about the depths of alcoholism or
something right and I just thought this
was such a crazy you know almost Darren
Aronofsky kind of script or whatever but
I I kept on going back to like wow would
I want to put money in this move because
they wanted some money or whatever uh
and I was like
I think I would put money in the movie
but I'd really have to have a very
um
big conversation with the other
producers and the director as to how
we're going to Market this film because
it's a very specific like critic driven
sort of like piece that we'd have to get
into like a Sundance or Tribeca or like
a con or something like that it's the
only way this movie is going to make its
money back right and so
um so the answer is yes I would take a
risk on certain things but you better
know how to Market that thing you better
know exactly how you're going to try to
get your money back because it's not
like the normal way you would within a
mainstream audience
how long did you Ponder this this script
um I pondered it up right up until
production when they were gonna make the
movie and I was about to write a check
for the movie however I found out sadly
there was some bad players involved with
the movie and uh I'm not going to name
something that but I I found out there
were some people like you should Google
everybody like I put it from an IMDb Pro
but sometimes you Google people and you
just have to come up with like this
person's name this person
ruinedmylife.com and you're like holy
[__] how did I overlook this and then
you're just like I can't be in business
with this person so that's the main
reason I didn't do it I loved the script
I loved everything about it I love the
director radio directors fantastic but
this other guy
didn't want to touch him with a 10-foot
Pole
how many pages of a screenplay will you
read before you move on I mean the whole
thing I mean it may take me six months
to read it but if I say I'm going to
read it and eventually you bug me enough
I will read it and I will give you notes
so that is typically at least you get
that from me
um but I'm I'm you know I try to read at
least a script today and I'm really
backlogged so I'm always trying to like
catch up really in some ways where do
you find these Scripts
um you know it's uh I have managers that
send things to me I have uh you know a
couple agents that you know feed me
stuff I have a lot of filmmaker friends
that we've made at the different film
festivals or just living in Los Angeles
really uh they're you know and then
they're successful people on their sort
of careers in some way and so they
always like send me stuff and like well
listen can you find me some money
sometimes but I can sometimes I can't um
sometimes it's something where we need
to go to somebody much bigger to raise
the money because it's like you know
much bigger budget but uh but I'm very
um I'm very into networking and I'm very
into
um you know surrounding myself with
hopefully talented people who are
consistently making interesting product
and who are consistently making
interesting scripts and stories
how did you find the screenplay for one
VR
um by uh ex-wife went to high school
with Allard Cantor uh Allard cancer and
Jared Murray are two managers that run a
company called epicenter and David
marmer our writer director was rep by
these guys so I had one of those lunches
that you have in Los Angeles where you
talk about the projects you're working
on another you know douche baggery and
uh you know uh at the end of that lunch
I was sent two Scripps uh and I never
read for six months and the reason was
in my own defense is we were about to go
to production on something else and it
was very you know pre-production and
that sort of like pit of Hell and I was
working very hard on them and that
project fell through and all of a sudden
I found myself looking you know for
scripts and I'm like oh let me read
these scripts I didn't read before and I
read those both of those scripts one of
them was a movie called tragedy girls
which is fantastic horror comedy
um and uh Craig Robinson and a bunch of
people are in it uh I I
I basically read that script and I said
no because horror comedy is tough to do
invariably you find that the horror
audience don't doesn't think it's scary
enough and the comedy audience is too
scary so I said that's a pass and they
told me hey that we just finished that
movie last week and I said what do I
know the second movie was one BR and
love the love the script I met with
David marmer right away and you know we
got along uh he uh you know very smart
sweet soft-spoken guy but really you
know knows what he wants
um so I immediately uh you know found
the script that way and uh you know
called my producing partner I was like
listen we gotta like we gotta you gotta
read this you gotta like we gotta we
gotta sign a letter of intent to like
you know to get an operating agreement
together and and start uh making this
our first film so that's how it started
so you did the Hollywood lunch you you
did the Hollywood lunch uh you know I
mean you say what you want about the
Hollywood lunch it's uh it's it's very
necessary I miss it I'll tell you this
stuff you go to Sundance and it's like
going to 500 meetings without having to
drive
that's what I think
but I wonder in some sense because you
know you're all feeling good you're
around like-minded people maybe it skews
it maybe it's better to have the lunch
because you're in La you're dealing with
all the stuff that's true to LA and it's
sort of like dating you want to know is
this going to work with this person sure
I mean like I'm sure that's that's uh
you know I mean it's the reason you meet
people in general I mean I met David
Warman for a coffee right and you know
we met the Culver Hotel and hung out and
I had a scone and like look you talk
about your sensibilities you talk about
what you're interested in you talk about
like is there is there something here do
we have like oh well I really love
Exorcist three I love Exorcist three
like I mean do you have the same
sensibilities
um I think that's that's another reason
that you meet with people but like look
uh you know that lunch or a coffee or
drinks or whatever it is is it's just
connection Any Which Way right that's
what we're talking about at the end of
the day are you connected to the person
could I work with this person can I work
with this person when the car breaks
down which invariably it will break down
like that's the whole idea about making
a movie the cartoon some breaking down
what do you do when the car breaks down
well you could yell and scream or you
can say okay what are we gonna do about
this now how are we going to solve this
problem right and you want like-minded
people right and so sometimes you
discover that when you're making movies
sometimes you just compare that before
the movie because you just kind of sense
this person is a nice person it's not a
yeller he's going to talk and I can be
the Yeller you know whatever it is like
good cop bad cop whatever it is right
but I think what you're trying to get
out I think it's more about connection
like that's the reason these lunches or
whatever they are drinks or coffees or
whatever you want to find out that they
have the you're like-minded you have the
same sensibilities and maybe you have
the same goals
and it's not just a year that you may be
tied to this person maybe several years
oh yeah so to know that as well like
this isn't just a one and done one year
and to be fair I didn't think that but
now I know that like I thought they'd be
done like oh we're shooting this thing
as a lark because it's 2017 December
it'll be out by uh next year no no and
then when it does come out it comes out
during covet so now we're you know
definitely like stuck together and we
didn't get everything we thought we
would get you know in terms of a
theatrical release or whatever it is you
know what was it in the screenplay for
one BR that made you want to make this
movie
um
it just wasn't expected I mean you know
the way it sort of read at the beginning
and I didn't know anything about it I
just went in cold right
uh first you think it may be something
Supernatural you may think it's a bunch
of different things a lot of sort of red
herrings going on and that turns out to
be something kind of really different
and something we haven't seen in a while
um if you know in a long while and then
it it actually is somewhat original in
addition to that the kind of twists and
turns like every act there's something
that pivots in a different way which I
hadn't seen hardly at all if not in a
long time
um and to be fair like it was on a
script level but it became even more in
the edit as well but on the script level
like it definitely was something much
different than we hadn't seen in a long
time and it was contained in terms of
the actual atmosphere was contained
which is important for a low budget film
uh you know
um CS that was sort of the unique thing
about it it was in our budget level it
definitely was something we hadn't seen
before and it went places we didn't
quite expect and it pivots at different
parts of the different acts it pivots in
different ways that it made it very sort
of interesting even on the page
and so when you took your your test
marketing your research brain how did it
measure up
well I mean look I I thought about
trailer moments right and you know it's
funny like uh it had trailer moments it
had it had definite trailer moments I
also knew that look like the performance
that this this young lady is going to
give Nicole bride and Bloom gave is
going to be key to the whole thing like
she literally is like the movie like the
her face has to emote and she has to
have that kind of face I mean Nicole has
these big eyes and she can just tell
there's like a million things going on
with her with her when she like you know
looks at the camera right we needed to
find like that particular actress and we
did thankfully we knew the ending was
extremely important
um you know we knew there were a little
we did little thing we knew there was
little things within the script that we
could toggle and and sort of make our
make our own in terms of like producers
giving some you know advice and
different things like that I mean like
that we had a torture song in there
right that happens in the movie without
getting like giving up too many spoilers
um but like um you know we went through
a couple different you know ideas of
this The Producers came up with ideas
and then you know David had ideas and we
were able to like you know get the right
song and everything else so that was
even sort of on the script level that we
sort of noticed that little things we
could do that would make the movie maybe
successful and some right in terms of
like or our traditional sense of of
successful in terms of like maybe a
mainstream thing
did you envision the audience who would
be watching this absolutely I mean look
we we knew that
um you know it was such a smart script
we knew that we had almost a almost a a
four quadrant audience of sorts uh you
know eight you know it's not nobody
under 18 is really about this movie I
don't think unfortunately like that's
what we see from like uh IMDb in
different uh places that have like um
you know uh demographics and and
different things like this data
um we knew that
um it's skew older weirdly it was a lot
of accessibility to the movie and in
fact it was confirmed in a way we went
in to for a meeting with Netflix and
Netflix told us you know why we like
your movie because this is the kind of
movie you can watch with your mom and we
were like oh wow I don't know whether to
be insulted or yeah I guess we're going
to take that as a compliment because
it's accessible
and we could we could see that sort of
on the script level too where okay it's
kind of thoughtful in certain ways there
is like violence to it but the way the
violence is framed was that it was
purposeful it wasn't gratuitous there's
nothing where we're trying to like you
know there's no you know you could go
different places with like movies that
people get sort of maybe
um put through the ringer let's call it
but we knew that this didn't have any of
that thankfully I mean it has some
elements of of horror and different
things like this I mean really the movie
is a psychological Thriller with
elements of horror right that's what we
Define it as so we knew that it had
enough of um these different elements to
be uh
to make it accessible to a wider
audience even on the page we also have a
strong supporting character who's older
and and I think they work well together
the protagonist in that character and it
also shows the goodness of your
protagonists in the dealings with
without giving away too much but I I
like that I thought that was um well I
mean the other thing on the page that
was interesting is that
even the so-called villains in the in
the film like they think they're doing
right like they really do believe that
they are helping people and clearly it's
misguided but you you almost kind of see
like our main character kind of see
their point of view which is interesting
in its own right too like she kind of
sees like okay this maybe could be a
good life you know maybe maybe these
rules are actually kind of necessary
misguided as they may be what's your
advice to screenwriters who are trying
to pitch their scripts and get them read
I think that you coming back to it
hopefully it's original if it's not
original hopefully something you haven't
seen in a long time or it's done in such
a way that it is a new spin on whatever
this maybe
standard genre thing could be right I
mean we have so many different like you
know Groundhog's Day movies now we have
the horror versions of them now we have
like you know the people that will take
it into a different twist I mean you
know Freaky Friday horror version is
freaky let's say okay well they kind of
did the same twist but differently right
they made it their own
um so I guess my advice is if you could
go original go original if you don't if
it's not original them have a new spin
on it so that it seems like it's
original
or you haven't seen it in a long time
those are the things the other thing too
is uh don't turn in anything that's
halfway done you're never gonna get a
second chance I'm not going to read it
again I can tell you that there's very
few people that I'd read a second script
a second time for if I didn't like it
the first time so you better when you're
gonna give it to somebody it better be
in its finest form like have all the
typos out of it have every you know
format it correctly just make sure
you're putting your best foot forward
when you're giving it to somebody to
read because they are spending their
time to read it too right you're trying
to make it there's been there time to
read it what about the school of thought
that like certain things are in style
for a short window of time so found
footage after Blair Witch now there's
all this found footage stuff for a while
and it's trendy it's what people want to
see what about going with the flow if
you can do it within a short window of
time
I mean look everyone's trying to make
terrifier too now right like terrifier 2
made a billion dollar well I mean like
13 million dollars but let's shop for
like 250 000 and now everyone's thinking
look if I can just put together this
Ultra gross movie I can maybe get it on
the big screen too
what they don't realize is that
terrifier 2 had like Ames eight to ten
years worth of awareness for that film
uh had was on you know Netflix and all
the avod platforms like the the
terrifier one from came out 2016. it's
2022. six years that movie had of like
people soaking it up and some people
actually liking the film so that when it
came out they didn't do any marketing
for that film they just put Lucid in 750
theaters maybe like a million three
million for opening weekend and went up
every weekend right that's because I had
awareness that was the main thing you
can't just jump on this bandwagon let's
call it and hope to like you know make
some money like they they try to do this
with uh uh the uh Grinch movie you're
the mean one or whatever which is not as
good as terrifier too by the way but
they tried to be jump on this bandwagon
oh this can be ultra gross and it's like
you know it's the Grinch and it should
be really interesting and didn't make
that much money compared to terrifier
two because terrified two is actually
good and had a lot of awareness for it
so but then but there's all look there's
always these things where okay the shark
movie is popular well you go to 2B
there's literally 100 shark movies oh
clown movies are popular there is a
shark clown movie on 2B right now but I
haven't watched but exists right there's
a Santa clown
shark movie on 2B right now right you
can try to take all these genres you
think are popular and make a movie and
maybe you'll make some money but you
know it's it's a trend try to do
something that people aren't doing right
try to do something that like you know
you haven't seen hopefully and other
people will copy you here's the funny
thing
so um Netflix rejected us twice before
they they took us the third time they
took us the third time because we did
well on VOD and we opened during kovitz
and no one was watching anything so
maybe that helped us too we took took
Netflix review and VOD numbers hey look
look we did pretty well and they're like
all right we'll take you we'll give you
no money but we'll take you so then fast
forward to us getting to number one and
saying the top five for like you know
eight days
our friends go in for a meeting with
Netflix and they're like it's gonna be a
pass we're looking for female in Peril
contained atmosphere everything we had
gotten reject before and now they're
looking for it right here's the truth of
it you write something original that's
interesting and then they'll copy you
right they don't believe until they
believe is the idea so that's why doing
something original maybe is not the
worst thing to do as long as you can
Market it
that's the main thing Rising above the
noise is the toughest part for most
filmmakers just so so easy to make a
movie nowadays there's hundreds of
horror movies all of them have better
post posters in the next But Rising
above the noise is the main thing if you
have something original it's even better